we're seeing we're seeing the border
crisis too turn some border towns that
were traditionally blue really red too
so that's that's absolutely mcallen
texas elected a republican mayor
yeah isn't it hilarious how as soon as
left-wing people actually have to face
the consequences of their policies
instead of getting to shove it off onto
somebody else they mysteriously turn red
or they leave yeah
think about it in this context because
we talked about getting the news out how
the news media twisted everything and
that's why i think it's important people
listen to this right you know did i
mention people ought to share this did i
mention that yes yes absolutely and you
are so correct leave a comment too
i didn't know if i mentioned that super
chat us but so they're not getting real
news down there but when they see
illegals coming across the border now
when i was in the state house i was on
the borders of committee my second term
i was the vice chair
and back then there were in that one
year there were it was 2010 11 rather
there was 5 000 texans who were either
hurt raped violently attacked
burglarized murdered killed
uh by people who shouldn't even be in
texas and let me do some math for you if
we've got 70 000 kids coming across the
border a month and we've had that if you
think about kindergarten education k
through 12. i was in the public
education committee for four years k
through 12 do this math if you've got 70
000 kids coming across the border let's
just say the average school k through 12
is 10 000.
that is seven complete school districts
that you have to fund
right somebody's got to fund now i get
that they don't all land and stay in
texas
you know we're the federal government is
their logistics group the drug lords
bring them up here human trafficking and
and we latch on to ngos and under the
biden administration and they move them
inland but somebody's going to pay to
educate those kids and that's per month
when we have those kinds of months seven
complete school districts per month yeah
so okay i mean for years the democrats
have argued that it's misinformation to
say that illegal immigrants receive any
kind of welfare state funding and
firstly there actually are illegal
immigrants who have family members who
are on welfare and so they receive it
that way but also when you enter into a
country and you're not registered in the
system and paying taxes but you're
receiving benefits from the system it's
functionally the exact same problem one
one of the uh
most interesting points that i was
reading about when it comes to illegal
immigration is how they affect the uh
presidential vote because the way we
vote is by electoral college right and
so when you get non-citizens in a
district they still count towards the uh
census right yeah so that means that
a state with a large population of
non-citizens will get
an extra district or two based on those
non-citizens which means an extra
electoral college vote that's right
texas got two texas got two this year
and by the way two extra seats because
of non-citizens well uh well
population growth well we had both i
mean it's it's hard to say how many our
our great border patrol and our great
texas dps and we've got a lot of folks
down on the border we love our law
enforcement down there when i was in the
texas house my first term we put 200
million dollars on the border and that
was for helicopters and boats and ships
gun boats literally we've got five boats
on the on rio grande river with machine
guns louie gomer and i've been down
there and actually toured that area
now they're putting three billion
dollars a session because they only meet
every other year two sessions two years
on the border and the federal
government's not doing their job yeah
they and so yeah we're growing we don't
know we don't know how many people we've
lost they will give you they will give
you the number that they handled and
then they'll give you an ex an estimate
on the getaways that they don't know how
many got away have you have you talked
to uh some of these people down in these
border districts as to what's going on
like what what are people thinking and
feeling as to why they're switching from
democrats absolutely i've been on the
border probably five or six times been
in there a number of times remember the
freedom call because we've been down
there i went down there really twice
when i was in the texas legislature and
then i've been there four five six times
i've been in congress and they're sick
and tired if you talk to the ranchers
and the farmers and the business owners
down there and the city officials
they're tired of biden's policy they're
tired of just letting them cross come
across it's unbelievable
i've heard some crazy stories oh listen
and you know this is sickening but
the drug lords down there they they will
make those young girls they'll take them
and they will be violated raped if you
will they will be violated numerous
times coming up across the border there
and they actually have trees where they
hang the the clothing of their victims
we're talking
women's underwear and stuff like that in
trees and they call them prison calm and
i've been there and seen
with my own eyes it's a it's appalling
and i don't get why the by the
administration the democrats don't see
that you know they need to stay in their
own country if they want to claim asylum
then let they can stay then go to the
embassy in that country when when you
give people accurate information it's
interesting how
the democrat narrative makes no sense so
for instance you go to a regular
american and say should the united
states help people who are fleeing gang
violence and need asylum they'll
probably say yes
you'll say then yet follow up
if these people are coming from say
brazil
should they be allowed to trek all the
way up through all of these countries
and through mexico into the united
states for asylum most people will say
wait what no once they've escaped the
danger they're safe where they are they
can stay there right that's right so
what's happening now is we're hearing
stories about people traveling from
ethiopia from africa over over overseas
absolutely to brazil and you know what
really offends me about this they land
in brazil and then they trek all the way
up to the united states brazil is
awesome right i i i was chilling on
copacaban on the beach of the coconut
and i'm like what about brazil do you
not i don't i don't understand but i
mean i get it america is it's the
benefits
we're we're a wealthier nation than
brazil and so they're safe in this
country
but they're willing to risk the lives of
their children and themselves because
america is just that much better well
you ask a regular person should we grant
them asylum they're going to say no
absolutely
well tim when i was there the director
of the dps there uh my youngest son is a
special agent for the fbi and
steve mccraw was a former fbi got
retired and rick perry appointed him and
we found out i had fbi family we had a
great relationship
and he told me that there's 40
different eastern religious sects
s-e-c-t-s
40 different this 2009
40 different eastern religious sects
coming across our southern porous border
we don't know who's here
we don't know who's here that ought to
scare people big time islamic extremists
are also making plans to come up from
from the horn of africa and they're
coming in i think it was like joseph
meyer somebody that had been tracking
that for a really long time i've
actually heard from several journalists
that extremist groups know they can
enter through the southern border rather
easily and that's one of the main ways
to get in yeah absolutely one of the
points you were making is about how as
soon as you have more information the
democratic narrative falls apart and
that's a huge part of the reason why
they have to call people names for
disagreeing with them and why they have
to frame every issue really dishonestly
so if you look at the conversation that
we're having on border security very
plainly it's essentially one group of
people saying
there should be some vetting of people
at the border we should have a handle on
who's in here people should become
citizens because we
as a democratic nation supposedly where
the people have a say should have some
say on who's entering the country the
other side of the discussion is
literally just
there should literally be zero oversight
on who is entering the country the
people should have absolutely no say
when you put it that way it's extremely
obvious which side of the issue you
should be on whether you consider
yourself liberal or conservative but the
way they frame it is well either you
think everyone should be able to come
here and get whatever benefits they want
or you're racist
yeah and look if we don't have a border
we're not a sovereign country and people
accuse me all the time randy and and by
the way i have a website randywebber.org
so if anybody wants to see what i
believe it's easy to find me
randyweber.org
but i i tell people all the time they
said well you just you just hate uh max
you know mexicans people south of the
border and hispanics and that kind of
stuff and i said no i said you don't
like immigration you just want to close
the whole border down i said no
my grandfather and my grandmother came
over on the boat from germany
i am the grandson of german immigrants i
wouldn't even be here but they guess
what they did it legally and that's what
we're saying come in to build the
country
don't come in to take from the country
and that's the difference well and not
only that it isn't simply an argument on
the ethics of why a person should want
to come here it's simply a statement
that we should have some handle on who's
coming here we should know who's in our
country it's constitutional congress
makes immigration naturalization laws
not the president of the united states
but we really need to think about why
they don't care why they think it should
be that way they they want these people
to come in because they want them again
dependent on them so that they they'll
get their votes and and they can
maintain more power and implement
their
progressive ideologies i think we should
uh allow every single person in the on
the planet
to immigrate to the united states
but it's got to be through a controlled
legal process which means there's also
going to be certain times at which we
can't allow people to come in what i
mean to say is everyone should have the
opportunity to try absolutely but this
means if we can't handle the burden it
means if we
we can figure out where people can go to
i went to sweden to explore the uh
refugee crisis and a lot of the claims
that were being made about it a lot of
people on the right were saying that
violent crime was through the roof
because of these refugees that were
coming from the war in the middle east
as it turns out while that was partly
true there was an increase in crime for
that reason a lot of the crime we were
seeing was due to the uh somali refugees
of the 80s and 90s and their children
growing up feeling stateless feeling
like they weren't part of the community
why what happened was when those people
came in in the 90s
sweden didn't track where they were
going what they were doing and so they
formed enclaves they went they were they
were told by sweden okay everybody move
here and then you're good
so then they had kids those kids grow up
in an area where everyone speaks the
same language but they're but they're
they're swedish citiz they're swedish
citizens but people in sweden who are
white you know natives did not view them
as swedish they viewed them as
immigrants then they would go home to
their home country to see their parents
and they would be called swedish so all
of a sudden you have these individuals
who feel stateless because they weren't
able to integrate they weren't given the
opportunity
the reason why you have checkpoints and
borders and an immigration process is to
maximize the opportunity for those who
are actually coming to the country if
you look at what the left is defending
with these porous borders it's children
wandering through 90 miles of open
desert being found dead in ditches being
being left without parents being left
sick one of the most disgusting things i
saw
there was a young child i think it was a
little girl maybe like 11 years old who
died and the news reports were like
child dies in ice custody and it's all
this all this crazy and then the story
actually was the ice
found a sick girl dying in the desert
and did everything in their power to try
and save her life and so they rushed to
the facility and she died and the media
tried framing it like they killed her i
remember that yep i've been there with
my own eyes and seeing the facilities
that they have and let me back up and
just say this too that look if we're
going to let
if congress is going to increase them
immigration quotas by country that we
have
that's up to congress that's
constitutional but we're going to have
to have the facilities and the
infrastructure do that we're going to
have to have immigration courts
immigration judges immigration officers
then we have to have facilities and so
it's going to cost the american taxpayer
more dollars so here's the question
shouldn't we when somebody comes to
america wants to immigrate and come
across the border should we charge them
fifty dollars a hundred dollars five
hundred dollars should they help pay for
the infrastructure absolutely absolutely
uscis already processes though a million
um petitions a year we let in about 500
000
immigrants from all over the place
every year and people don't realize that
we have we take in the most amount of
immigrants
out of any other nation in the entire
world
our immigration system while it it has
its issues is still
letting in so many people think about
that you're letting in 500 000 people
legally a year on on green card
petitions and they process a million
applications yeah to your point about
how much should people pay when they
come in some of these stories you we
hear about families spending three
thousand dollars or more or more and so
it's fascinating to me that the
narrative from the left is often oh
these poor refugees who are so broke and
helpless and i'm like they got three
grand paid drug cartels yeah to be
trafficked up here and it's dangerous
you know they don't got 50 bucks to help
us afford the cost to make sure that i
mean we're talking about helping people
who are genuine asylees or whatever get
get proper placement that means we need
infrastructure we got to pay for it it
does cost money to immigrate here
through like uscis but we they have fee
petition waivers that you can you can
fill out and you can come here for free
you can you know fill out all the
paperwork and file it with uscis if you
file a feed petition waiver and claim
some hardship so it's actually less
expensive to do it the right way yeah
than it is to to come over and be
smuggled by drug cartel unless you're
trying to break through the border and
sneak into the country thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you